flood water wreaking havoc across
china's hernan province
the damage visible as far as the eye can
see
the army is warning one of the region's
seven stricken dams may collapse at any
time
risking the lives of around seven
million people
heavy downpours have flooded streets
stranding travellers
bringing the region to a standstill cars
are completely submerged
as residents are swept away
underground unmistakable panic among
these passengers
trapped inside a submerged subway car
waist deep waters rising to their
shoulders
emergency crews reportedly opening a
hole in the roof
evacuating passengers one by one
this terrifying moment shows bystanders
swallowed by a sinkhole
with a crowd rescuing this woman
a deafening explosion at this aluminium
factory after a nearby river bursts its
banks
the flood water mixed with chemicals
lighting up the night sky
the government has been upgrading its
emergency response with crews working
round the clock to rescue residents
inside their flooded homes
and cars increased urbanization and
climate change has worsened the impact
of floods in recent years
this is the most rainfall the region has
seen in six decades
with no sign of letting up anytime soon
and katrina joins us live now from
beijing katrina so this flooding in
hernan province has been pretty severe i
mean how badly
has it affected critical infrastructure
in the region
hi darren well there are at least five
million people living in the city of
zhengzhou
and many of them are currently without
electricity fresh running water
internet or gas many locals that we have
spoken to are actually going into their
cars and using their cars to charge
their mobile phones
which are their only connection to the
outside world
in terms of other infrastructure most
public transport has been suspended so
many roads main roads are blocked
they're flooded
buses have been cancelled subways have
been closed as well as the airport
now a hundred thousand people have been
relocated because
of this wet weather uh unprecedented for
many of these
locals in their lifetimes many that we
have spoken to have said this is the
worst that they've ever
seen it uh those who can stay home uh
have been warned by the government to
remain indoors
to stay safe now it's been raining quite
heavily
in zhengzhou for at least three days but
the worst of it
came on tuesday afternoon uh at about 4
p.m to 5 p.m local time in the space of
just
one hour 20 centimeters of rain fell and
many of the subways in the eastern part
of the city the most
the most low-lying part of the city were
quickly submerged and that's where
tragically
many of these 12 people who are have uh
who have been confirmed dead
had lost their lives now the government
has sent in uh 10 000 people
a mixture of firefighters and soldiers
to participate in this rescue
operation and the warning level the
emergency level remains at its highest
but it's
not just jung joe the city that has been
affected
neighboring areas are also affected as
well as the city of loyola which is
about 130 uh 30 kilometers
to the west of jungjo now this city has
a very
crucial dam the ihetan dam which was
breached
overnight by 20 meters of water
authorities
announced a warning that this dam could
collapse at any moment they are
monitoring it and reinforcing it
as we speak and overnight authorities
also exploded parts of the dam in the
lower
parts of the river to relieve pressure
on that dam and protect the seven
million people who live
in the city of law young but they're
still working very hard
with authorities on high alert heavy
rain is expected for at least
another two days and many locals say
they are terrified and shocked
and trying to stay safe and as dry as
possible
all right katrina you life was there in
beijing katrina thank you